en france on a la chance de vivre en
démocratie et on est évidemment une très
grande majorité à penser qu'il s'agit du
meilleur des systèmes politiques
une des choses qui implique la
démocratie c'est que le peuple a le
pouvoir de choisir ceux qu'ils
gouvernent très bien mais la manière
qu'on a de les choisir c'est à dire
notre système de vote
est ce qu'on est sûr qu'il est le
meilleur et ben non pas vraiment il est
même assez mauvais et en fait on
pourrait faire beaucoup mieux
en france sous la vème république
l'élection reine c'est évidemment
l'élection présidentielle et elle se
déroule dans ce qu'on appelle un scrutin
uninominal à deux tours alors uninominal
ça veut dire qu'on ne vote que pour une
seule personne
au premier tour on a plein de candidats
et on garde les deux meilleurs pour les
départager au deuxième tour ça paraît
simple comme système au point qu'on voit
pas très bien comment on pourrait faire
beaucoup mieux que ça et pourtant on
sait que ce système de vote il produit
des dysfonctionnements l'exemple typique
c'est évidemment l'élection
présidentielle de 2002 alors petit
rappel pour ceux qui s'en souviennent
pas ou qui n'était pas née le 21 avril
2002 au premier tour jacques chirac qui
était le président sortant arrive en
tête avec 19 9% des voix et à la
surprise générale c'est jean marie le
pen qui termine deuxième avec 16 9%
juste devant lionel jospin à 16,2 et on
a donc un second tour chirac le pen et
chirac l'emportent largement
ce qui est bizarre dans le déroulement
de cette élection c'est que lionel
jospin se trouve éliminé de peu alors
que les sondages de l'époque montrer que
s'il avait été au deuxième tour il
aurait peut-être gagné aussi bien face à
le pen que face à chirac alors à
l'époque on avait attribué l'élimination
de lionel jospin à la présence d'autres
petites candidatures à gauche il y avait
notamment jean pierre chevènement qui
avait fait 5,3 pour cent et christiane
taubira qu'avait fait 2,3 on avait déjà
vu plus ou moins la même chose dans
l'élection précédente celle de 1995
edouard balladur qui était archi favori
quelques semaines avant le scrutin s'est
fait sortir de peu du premier tour et on
pense que si philippe de villiers qui
avait fait 4 7% s'était pas présenté
c'est peut-être balladur qui aurait été
au 2e tour à la place de chirac
le problème dans ces élections c'est
évidemment parce qu'on pense de jospin
le pen ou balladur non c'est le fait que
à chaque fois on a un candidat qui a une
chance réelle de l'emporter et qui se
trouve mis hors course à cause de la
présence d'un petit candidat proche de
son camp qui lui n'a aucune chance
d'aller au bout
c'est quand même vraiment bizarre comme
situation tenet supposer qu'on ait ça en
sport imaginez qu'à la finale du 100 m
aux jeux olympiques ça se joue entre
deux trois grands favoris et que les
petits candidats ceux qui ont aucune
chance de remporter la médaille et le
droit de retenir les favoris par le
short et que finalement celui qui gagne
la course soit pas forcément celui qui
court le plus vite mais celui qui aura
réussi à se faire le moins retenir par
le short on trouve ça complètement
stupide antisportif absurde injuste et
pourtant c'est exactement ça qui se
passe à l'élection présidentielle
l'issue du scrutin et influencer de
manière
easy par la présence ou l'absence de
certains petits candidats et on trouve
ça juste alors qu'on parle d'un truc est
quand même autrement plus important que
la finale du 100 m c'est quand même
juste que l'avenir du pays mais bon on
s'est habitué à vivre avec cette
bizarrerie démocratique au point qu on
la trouverait presque normale et pour la
compenser on a inventé un truc qui
s'appelle le vote utile
le principe du vote utile c'est de se
forcer à ne pas voter pour le candidat
qu'on préfère celui qu'on souhaite très
sincèrement voir et lui met à voter pour
un candidat qu'on aime moins mais qui
est mieux placé en plus à côté du vote
utile
il yal inverse le vote protestataire qui
consiste justement à voter pour
quelqu'un que dans le fond on
souhaiterait pas franchement voir et du
bon donc au final on est en démocratie
c'est super on peut choisir nos
dirigeants très bien mais la méthode par
laquelle on les choisit est complètement
buggé
c'est quand même un peu dommage non
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas trouver une
manière différente d'élire le président
ou la présidente qui évite tous ces
problèmes
un mode de scrutin qu'ils soient plus
efficaces plus robustes plus
représentatif et bien figurez vous que
cette question elle a été étudiée par
des politologues et des mathématiciens
et qu'on peut l'aborder sous l'angle de
la science
ce qui ne va pas dans le système actuel
on l'a vu c'est que le score de
candidats mineurs qui n'ont aucune
chance de l'emporter peut décider de qui
passent au second tour et donc du
vainqueur potentiel
alors petite parenthèse cette situation
elle est pas spécifique à la france aux
etats-unis c'est même encore pire
puisqu'il ya qu un tour de scrutin alors
leur tradition politique est fait pour
que normalement n'y ait que deux
candidats mais bondées que c'est pas le
cas c'est le bordel en 1992 george bush
le père se représentait contre bill
clinton est normalement bush aurait dû
l'emporter
sauf qu'il ya eu un troisième candidat
ross pérot un indépendant plutôt à
droite qui avait fait presque 20 % et
donc avait pris une partie des voix de
bouche et c'est bill clinton qui avait
gagné pour éviter ce genre de situation
que ce soit en france aux etats-unis une
solution ça serait peut-être de faire
plus de tours de scrutin dans sa forme
extrême on pourrait même imaginer qu'on
élimine un seul candidat à chaque tour
et ont fait autant de tours que
nécessaire pour désigner un vainqueur
si on faisait comme ça chacun serait
libre de voter pour un petit candidat
dans les premiers tours si c'est
vraiment sa conviction sans que ce soit
ça qui est une influence déterminante
sur le scrutin
alors là vous allez me dire ce système
est quand même un peu compliqué à la
dernière élection présidentielle il y
avait dix candidats donc on aurait dû
faire neuf tours de scrutin et donc on
aurait mis plusieurs mois à élire le
président et bien non en fait on n'a pas
besoin de faire autant de tours de
scrutin il existe une solution pour
régler le problème en un seul tour
l'idée c'est de demander aux électeurs
non plus de mettre un seul bulletin dans
l'urne
mais de classer tous les candidats par
ordre de préférence avec ça on peut
déterminer le résultat de tous les tours
de scrutin les uns après les autres
alors voici comment on fait pour simuler
le premier tour on regarde seulement le
premier choix de chaque électeur
on calcule le pourcentage des votes que
chaque candidat a obtenu et on regarde
qui est arrivé dernier ce dernier on
élimine c'est à dire qu'on le retire du
classement de chacun des électeurs pour
simuler le deuxième tour on prend à
nouveau le premier choix de chaque
électeur sauf pour ceux qui avaient
classé premier le candidat qui doivent
être éliminés
pour cela on se reporte sur leur
deuxième choix on calcule à nouveau les
pourcentages obtenus par chaque candidat
on trouve le dernier et on élimine et on
recommence comme ça jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y
ait plus que deux candidats et qu'on
puisse désigner un vainqueur
cette méthode de scrutin elle existe
vraiment on l'appelle le vote alternatif
et elle est utilisée notamment pour
élire la chambre des représentants en
australie pour lire le président
irlandais et dans certaines
municipalités américaines alors la
supériorité de cette méthode
par rapport à notre scrutin à deux tours
c'est qu'elle nous permet de bien mieux
exprimer nos opinions
le problème du scrutin uninominal c'est
que quand on vote pour quelqu'un on ne
dit absolument rien de ce qu'on pense de
tous les autres c'est-à-dire qu'on
réduit toute la complexité de nos
opinions sur les candidats au choix d'un
seul nom alors qu'avec le vote
alternatif on peut exprimer de manière
beaucoup plus riches nos préférences
puisqu'on classe tous les candidats
alors est ce que c'est la méthode de
scrutin parfaite ce vote alternatif et
ben non pas vraiment en fait
bon déjà pour les lecteurs n est pas
super simple en général on sait les
candidats qu'on aime ou qu'on déteste
mais arrivé à classer tous les candidats
quand il y en a dix ou douze c'est pas
toujours évident et puis cette méthode
de scrutin elle permet de traiter les
cas où il ya plein de petits candidats
comme en france mais dès qu'on se
retrouve à arriver à l'avant dernier
tour il n'y a plus que trois candidats
et on se retrouve dans la situation
habituelle celle d'un scrutin à deux
tours et on va voir qu'avec trois
candidats et deux tours il peut déjà se
passer des choses absurdes
alors imaginons qu'on est plus que deux
tours que ça soit du vote alternatif ou
bien un scrutin classique à deux tours
comme on le fait aujourd'hui
supposons qu'on est trois candidats
françois nicolas et marine alors oui je
fais exprès de prendre des personnes
réelles pour que vous puissiez mieux
visualiser les choses mais ce que je
vais illustrer est tout à fait général
un cellier aux mathématiques du vote et
donc c'est pas dépendants de ces
personnes là où des camps qu'elle
représente
supposons que 34 % de l'électorat
choisissent de classe et françois devant
nicolas et nicolas devant marine que 32%
des gens préfèrent nicolas à françois et
françois à marine et que 34% des gens
préfèrent marine à nicolas et nicolas à
françois c'est une situation simplifiée
mais c'est relativement crédible en
simulant premier tour chacun vote pour
son candidat préféré françois fait 34 %
marino 6 et nicolas seulement 32% donc
il est éliminé simulons maintenant le
deuxième tour ceux qui avaient voté pour
nicolas au premier tour se reportent sur
françois donc françois fait 66 % et
marine 34% et donc françois est
largement élu ok maintenant imaginons
que les choses ne se soit pas passé
comme ça il m'a dit donc françois effet
une campagne plus efficace et qu'il ait
réussi à prendre trois pour cent de
l'électorat à marine on aura donc les
pourcentages suivants pour les
différents classements françois-nicolas
marine 37%
nicolas françois marine toujours 32 % et
marine nicolas françois 31% alors on
simule le premier tour
françois a fait 37 % nicolas 32 et
marine 31 donc c'est marine qui est
éliminée au premier tour et si on simule
le deuxième tour eh bien cette fois on à
nicolas 63 et françois 37
vous voyez le paradoxe dans la première
situation françois élu messi récupère
plus d'électeurs il peut se retrouver
perdant c'est ce qu'on appelle parfois
le paradoxe d'art où que ce soit dans un
scrutin classique à deux tours ou dans
le vote alternatif en progressant dans
l'opinion on peut se retrouver à
descendre dans le classement
c'est quand même absurde outre le fait
que c'est totalement incohérent comme
situation ça ouvre la porte à ce qu'on
appelle du vote stratégique
ici les partisans d'un candidat françois
aurait intérêt à ne pas voter pour lui
au 1er tour et à voter pour marine pour
lui faciliter le deuxième tour le vote
stratégique c'est quand on ne vote pas
selon ses convictions mais qu'on
exploite les failles du système pour
aider son candidat allait autre paradoxe
du système classique
imaginons trois candidats ségolène
nicolas et françois je continue de
prendre des cas réels
alors notez quand même que c'est pas le
même françois 1 alors imaginons que
l'opinion les classes de la manière
suivante 40% des électeurs préfèrent
nicolas françois et françois à ségolène
pour faire simple vous pouvez les
appeler les électeurs de droite 40 %
préfèrent ségolène à françois et
françois nicolas les électeurs de gauche
10 % préfèrent françois à nicolas et
nicolas à ségolène on peut les appeler
centre-droit et 10 % préfèrent françois
à ségolène et ségolène à nicolas les
centre gauche alors allons-y simulant
premier tour on prend le premier choix
de chaque électeur nicolas et ségolène
font 40 % françois ne fait que 20 % et
se retrouve éliminé et le deuxième tour
va se jouer entre nicolas et ségolène et
pourtant si on faisait un duel françois
nicolas et bien françois gagnerait 60 40
et si on faisait un duel françois
ségolène et ben ils gagneraient aussi
donc françois serait capable de battre
chacun des finalistes mais il n'arrive
pas à aller en finale encore une fois si
on fait la comparaison avec le sport
c'est quand même un peu bizarre alors
cet exemple il n'est pas totalement
fictif à l'élection présidentielle de
2007 il y avait douze candidats et les
sondages de l'époque prédisait que
françois bayrou aurait battu en duel
n'importe lequel des onze autres
candidats sauf qu'il n'a pas réussi à
aller au deuxième tour
cette situation elles datent pas d'hier
elle avait déjà été remarqué en 1785 par
le marquis de condorcet un philosophe et
mathématicien qui a été le premier à
s'intéresser au système de vote de
manière scientifique et sur la base de
sept
constatation condorcet avait proposé une
méthode de vote qui porte son nom la
méthode de condorcet on organise des
duels entre tous les candidats des duels
électoraux 1 100 ans et on garde celui
qui réussit à battre tous les autres ça
paraît super sauf que condorcet avait
remarqué qu'il ya des situations où ça
marche pas il existe des cas où aucun
candidat ne peut être en capacité de
battre tous les autres et ça crée des
choses vraiment bizarre à les imaginer
qu'on est trois candidats alors on va
changer un peu on va les appeler à b et
c
supposer qu'un tiers de l'opinion
préfère a à b b à c un tiers préfère b à
c est ca et le dernier tiers ca et à ab
si on fait un duel à contrebas donc on
enlève c est la gagne si on fait 1 du lb
contre ccb qui gagne mais dans un duel
contre c est bien c c qui gagne c'est à
dire qu aucun des trois candidats ne
peut gagner ses deux duels
c'est quand même bizarre eh ben on
appelle ça le paradoxe de condorcet ce
qui est étonnant c'est que imaginer que
a été élu par n'importe quelle méthode
de scrutin dès le soir de son élection
si on faisait un référendum il y aurait
les deux tiers de la population qui
serait d'accord pour le remplacer
immédiatement par c et puisque sebaâ
dans l'opinion
mais si on fait ça les deux tiers de la
population serait tout de suite d'accord
pour destituer c'est au profit de b
puisque beiba c'est dans l'opinion
sauf que si c b le président les deux
tiers la population serait d'accord pour
revenir à a bomb a donc faut trouver
autre chose à un contemporain de
condorcet avec qu'il avait pas mal
discuté le marquis de borda avait
proposé une variante comme dans le vote
alternatif chacun classe tous les
candidats et ensuite pour les départager
on leur file des points comme à
l'eurovision par exemple un point au
dernier deux points à l'avant-dernier
trois points à l'amour avant dernier et
c est n points au premier s'il ya un
candidat est celui qui a le plus de
points gagne si on applique ce mode de
scrutin à notre situation avec françois
nicolas et ségolène on se retrouverait
avec 190 points pour nicolas et ségolène
et 220 points pour françois qui sera
donc élue ce mode de scrutin il est par
exemple utilisé dans certains prix
sportif et aussi pour certaines élection
à l'académie des sciences
alors il paraît parfait non et ben non
pas vraiment bon déjà il dépend de la
manière dont on choisit de distribuer
les points et puis comme dans le scrutin
majoritaire classique les petits
candidats peuvent avoir une influence
décisive sur le résultat final donc non
il est pas vraiment idéal
tout ça est un peu décourageant on a
regardé plusieurs systèmes électoraux et
aucun ne semble parfaitement
satisfaisant mais bon au moins on sait
déjà préciser un peu ce qu'on cherche
on voudrait un système de vote qui
satisfasse au moins deux conditions la
première c'est que quand on progresse
dans l'opinion on ne peut que progresser
à la fin et on a vu qu'avec le scrutin
majoritaire classique c'est pas le cas
la deuxième c'est qu'on voudrait que le
résultat final ne soit pas dépendant de
la joue ou du retrait d'un candidat
mineur qui n'a aucune chance d'aller au
bout
quand vos 100 m quoi cette question elle
a été étudié scientifiquement par un
économiste américain qui s'appelle
kenneth arrow et arrow a démontré un
résultat qui porte le nom de théorèmes
d'impossibilité et en gros ce théorème
dit qu'il n'existe aucun système
électoral qui puisse satisfaire ces deux
conditions
ben voilà game over le système électoral
parfait n'existe pas c'est quand même un
peu déprimant non le théorème
d'impossibilité nous dit que quoi qu'on
fasse on pourra jamais lire correctement
les gens qui nous dirigent
sauf que le théorème d'arreau ne porte
que sur les systèmes de vote où on
exprime nos préférences en classant les
candidats mais en fait on peut y
échapper
en utilisant un système de vote on ne
classe pas les candidats mais on les
juge
individuellement il ya un système
électoral très simple qui permet de
faire ça c'est le vote par approbation
dans ce système on peut voter pour
autant de candidats qu'on veut alors on
peut évidemment pas voter plusieurs fois
pour le même mais on peut choisir de
donner sa voix à tous les candidats
qu'on approuve à l'issue de ce scrutin
on a le pourcentage d'approbation de
chaque candidat c'est-à-dire la fraction
de l'électorat qui a choisi de
l'approuver et ce mode de scrutin il est
totalement insensible au jeu des petites
candidatures s'il ya plusieurs candidats
qui vous plaisent et ben vous votez pour
tout cela il n'y a pas besoin de faire
du vote utile
un des gros avantages de ce système
c'est qu'il serait extrêmement simple à
mettre en place et à dépouiller avec le
fonctionnement actuel il suffit juste de
dire qu'on a le droit de mettre
plusieurs bulletins dans l' enveloppe un
seul tour de scrutin et basta le
problème de ce système c'est qu'il ya
pas de gradation dans l'approbation
c'est à dire que vous pouvez pas nuancé
entre un candidat que vous appréciez
vraiment et un candidat que vous tolérez
ouvriers faute de mieux pour aller plus
loin il faudrait être capable de juger
les candidats sur une échelle ça rien de
révolutionnaire comme proposition c'est
ce qu'on fait quand on a besoin de
classe et des élèves des films bien des
gymnastes alors pourquoi pas des hommes
politiques
on pourrait tout simplement imaginer
leur maître à tous une note entre 0 et
20 bon un problème c'est qu'il faudrait
trouver une échelle commune parce que 15
sur 20 ça va
pas forcément dire la même chose pour
vous et pour moi le problème c'est qu'on
pourrait aussi peser sur le vote en
exagérant ses notes par exemple votre
candidat préféré vous lui mettez vingt
et vous mettez 0 à tous les autres même
si dans le fond c'est parce que vous
pensez
ouais bon au final élire le président ou
la présidente en mettant des notes entre
0 et 20 à tous les candidats
c'est peut-être pas une super idée pour
éviter ces travers il ya deux chercheurs
français
rida laraki et michel balinski qui ont
proposé une méthode de vote qui permet
d'éviter tous les problèmes dont on a
parlé aujourd'hui on l'appelle la
méthode du jugement majoritaire
cette méthode est extrêmement simple à
mettre en oeuvre au lieu de mettre des
notes aux candidats on leur attribue une
mention un peu comme au bac sur une
échelle qui en compte 7
excellent très bien bien assez bien
passable insuffisant et à rejeter le
bulletin de vote ressemble à ça un pour
présider à la france ayant pris tous les
éléments en considération
je juge en conscience que ces candidats
seraient et pour chaque candidat vous
cochez une mention alors comment on
dépouille sera ensuite et bien pour
chaque candidat vous obtenez un
pourcentage pour chacune des mentions à
prendre un exemple fictif
imaginons un candidat auquel neuf pour
cent des gens aurait attribué la mention
excellent très bien 14% bien 16% assez
bien 15% passable 18% insuffisant 15% à
rejeter 13 % ont représenté
graphiquement comme ça alors comment on
interprète ça vous voyez que 9 % de
l'électorat accorderait la mention
excellent à ce candidat mais 23% c'est à
dire neuf +14 lui accorderait au minimum
très bien c'est à dire soit très bien
soit excellent et 39% accorderait au
minimum bien et de même 54 % de
l'électorat lui accorderait au minimum
assez bien la mention assez bien c'est
ce qu'on appelle la mention majoritaire
de ce candidat c'est la mention que plus
de la moitié de l'opinion ici 54 %
seraient prêts à lui attribuer pour
trouver rapidement la mention
majoritaire d'un candidat bas c'est très
simple vous représentez les pourcentages
de toutes ces mentions de cette manière
et vous tirer un trait à 50%
l'invention sur laquelle vous tombez et
sa mention majoritaire du coup pour
départager tous les candidats on regarde
pour chacun quelle est sa mention
majoritaire
celle qui est approuvée par au moins 50
% de l'opinion et celui avec la
meilleure mention majoritaire gagne et
en cas d'égalité ben on peut départager
avec les pourcentages et voilà ce qu'on
appelle la méthode du jugement
majoritaire et on pourrait très bien
utiliser cette méthode de scrutin pour
élire le président ou la présidente de
la république
alors qu'est ce qui fait que cette
méthode est si bonne déjà chaque
candidat est jugé individuellement sur
son mérite personnel
indépendamment des autres et donc on n'a
pas le problème des petites candidatures
qui vont influencer l'issue du scrutin
ici s'il ya plus de petites candidatures
ça ne va pas changer la mention
majoritaire qu'un candidat va recevoir
du coup avec la méthode du juge
majoritaire n'y a pas de notion de vote
utile vous avez juste à exprimer
sincèrement votre opinion sur chacun des
candidats l'autre avantage de ce système
c'est qu'il échappe ou paradoxe d'arreau
c'est à dire qu'un candidat qui
progresse dans l'opinion ne peut pas
régressé dans le classement final
en plus avec ce système du jugement
majoritaire on n'a aucun intérêt à voter
stratégiques c'est-à-dire à exagérer son
vote pour essayer d'aider son candidat
si votre candidat il a obtenu une
mention majoritaire assez bien que vous
ayez voté bien très bien où excellent et
ben ça change rien vous n'avez pas
exagérer votre vote vous avez juste à
voter sincèrement selon vos convictions
personnelles
autre avantage de ce système si tous les
candidats obtiennent comme mention
majoritaire soit insuffisant soit à
rejeter
on peut décider d'organiser de nouvelles
élections en exigeant de nouveaux
candidats et en interdisant à cela de se
représenter
voyez qu'une nouvelle méthode de vote
comme celle du jugement majoritaire
permettrait de choisir ceux qui nous
dirigent de manière moins aléatoire et
plus représentatives et peut-être de
réconcilier le peuple avec ses élites
politiques
si vous aussi vous pensez qu'on peut
choisir un meilleur système de scrutin
pour élire le président n'hésitez pas à
partager cette vidéo notamment pour
faire connaître la méthode du jugement
majoritaire
si vous voulez en savoir plus j'ai créé
un petit billet de blog pour apporter
quelques compléments et vous pouvez
aussi aller voir cette vidéo de la
chaîne la statistique expliquer à vos
chats qui montrent de manière assez
remarquable comment avec les mêmes
chiffres suivants le système de vote
qu'on utilise on peut obtenir un
résultat différent
bien sûr comme toujours si vous aimez la
science vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne pour ne rien rater
vous pouvez suivre les actualités sur
facebook sur twitter et vous pouvez
aussi me soutenir sur tipi merci à tous
et à bientôt
il